you've got mcdonald's you've got amazon  celebrating pride  after donating hundreds of thousands of  dollars to politicians who voted against  the equality act uh the same  these same three companies amazon  walmart and mcdonald's  collectively donated more than one  million dollars to lawmakers  who voted against the equality act now  in february the vast majority of  republicans in the house of  representatives  voted against the equality act the  equality act was  the goal was to expand lgbtq protections  and if you look at sec filings you will  see that  a lot of the best known companies in the  united states and that includes the ones  i mentioned  donated a whole bunch of money to  politicians who voted against the bill